the truth is that it's hard to bring
that baby to term to deliver to take
care of it to figure out what Mommy and
Daddy need to do how to make a living
how to take care of this life or it's
hard even finding the right adoption
program bringing that baby to term and
then watching them carry it away to
another family who will love and care
for it because you couldn't I get it
that's really hard the truth is hard
sometimes my clubs for closers and I
wanted to go back to something what
we're talking about abortion laws in the
country and I know that there are some
tweets out there and a lot of people I
guess are more easily shocked than
myself respond to these stories you know
I'm like how could you how could you do
that to a baby
how can someone go so far I hear that a
lot for many it boggles the mind doesn't
boggle mine and as much as it pains me
to say it I would say it's actually
entirely expected for two reasons one
the same reason I talk about this a lot
in the show but the truth and most
people's aversion to it and to the easy
way out and the two by the way in most
cases are one in the same I often talk
about the truth in the show and how
simple in theory life would be if you're
seeking it and another minute by the way
I know I'm gonna get some edgy smartass
atheists commenting you're saying what
the truth who do you believe in the
Flying Spaghetti Monster huh okay well
here's a brain twister not all societies
have considered truth to virtue and
certainly not more valuable than
successful outcomes so where is the
morality of truth seeking come from
there's a brain twister same thing with
mercy and compassion those are almost
exclusively found with modern
Christendom they were seen as weaknesses
so truth seeking is not innate as a
matter of fact often and I would say
more often than not it's the polar
opposite of human nature now keep in
mind I'm not talking about a truth or
your truth here I'm talking about the
truth people will often do whatever they
can to avoid it at all costs like an ant
with a magnifying glass effectively for
the same reason because here's an irony
this is something a lot of people aren't
going to like to hear but I'm going to
tie this back to the abortion thing a
little bit and irony is that when it
comes to the truth we've been lied to
we've been told that the truth will set
you free
guess what nope sometimes the truth come
the shackles sometimes the truth comes
with punishment sometimes the truth
sucks the truth will set you free
okay Your Honor I confess guilty life
without parole
what happened sometimes the truth is
hard but that doesn't change the fact
that it's the right thing to do and that
brings me to point number two the easy
way out I've talked about this before
you can go through the archives there is
almost always an easy way out in life or
at least an easier way out okay and I'm
not talking about by the way the the
most efficient path possible sometimes
the hard road is just wasted energy I
understand that don't get this part
twisted okay what I am talking about in
life is when faced with an uncomfortable
truth isn't it interesting how life
always offers you an open door next to
it almost invariably an easier door
think about it I want you to take some
time here and think about every single
decision that you've made in your life
where you had to stand up or or walk in
truth tell me there wasn't an easier way
tell me there wasn't an opt-out that's
why people kill 40 week old babies
that's how entire state legislators
smile upon the murder of twenty five
thirty forty week old babies the problem
didn't start with 40 week old babies it
started with plan B it started with the
early term abortions it started with
absolving oneself of responsibility in
turning one's back on the truth okay so
what you screwed up you're irresponsible
you lack self-control and now you've
brought a life into this world the truth
is you have no right to end that life
let me give you a little bit more leeway
okay let's say you were responsible
every single step of the way you use
protection okay little tadpole got
through for some reason here you are the
truth is that is still a life an
entirely separate genetic code that
cannot speak for itself
and you still have no right to decide
whether it lives or dies the truth is
that it's hard to bring that baby to
term to deliver to take care of it to
figure out what mommy and daddy need to
do how to make a living how to take care
of this life or it's hard even finding
the right adoption program bringing that
baby to term and then watching them
carry it away to another family who will
love and care for it because you
couldn't I get it that's really hard the
truth is hard sometimes or or
you could just take a pill or you could
just put your feet in those stirrups you
could grease the palms of a doctor and
be done with it in an afternoon now let
me clarify here am I saying that women
out there who get abortions are taking
the easy way out you're damn right I am
absolutely just like I think fathers who
shirk their responsibilities are taking
a cowards backdoor okay I'm not
absolving anyone here but the truth is
hard and there's always an easy way out
and that's why I hate bumper sticker
slogans and false platitudes you you
really do hear me try to avoid these on
this show because we use these so often
to lie to ourselves to hide the gritty
truth and to polish a lie right failure
is not an option
my friend Sheila's talked about this
that's a lot it's always an option it's
often the easiest and most readily
available option you just don't want to
admit the truth that you might fail we
hear this other one all the time I think
we did it in the parody of a any given
Sunday with Al Pacino in a fight it's
the guy who's willing to die who's gonna
win that fight it's the guy who's
willing to die he's the one who's gonna
taste victory
that's a lie in a fight it's the person
who's best prepared who's trained with
the most discipline and is the most
capable who will win do you know what we
call untrained men who go into fights or
battles willing to die dead that's the
truth but it's a lot easier to accept a
bumper sticker slogan that's motivating
than it is the truth here's the thing
while the truth may not immediately set
you free in the short term that's a cold
hard truth a lot of people don't want to
acknowledge well the truth may burn
sting or scar it is ultimately the only
path you can walk long term to live your
life as freely as humanly possible and
again before we go I want you to think
of every difficult decision in your life
you've ever made standing up for the
truth okay I really want you to picture
in your mind's eye here okay
remember the easy way out do you
remember the other options available at
that time got it
did you look back now look ahead where
do you see the truth where do you see
the easy way out because if you picked
the wrong path now they're only going to
be more and more paths
splitting getting easier and easier
leading you away from the path of truth
and into the permanent shackles created
by the lies of the world that's how you
kill a 40 week old baby you're
pro-choice okay are you paying attention
make the right choice okay if you liked
this video this is the part where I
would usually tell you to subscribe but
I can't do it anymore I'm going to tell
you to subscribe and then YouTube is
going to decide that we can't reach you
even though you subscribe to this
channel and then I'll say hit the
notification bell and then the
notification bell won't even be there
anymore I don't know what to say more
than likely you'll find my face in a
milk carton but do what you can to stop
it it's just it's just
it probably won't do much